my mother had Emily name even my mother
always used to sew and at some point she
taught me how to thread a needle and I
started sewing for friends who worked in
the theatre that's surely the nice thing
about sewing is that you always have
something to show for it you got
something that you can touch and it's so
great to see how much people enjoy
getting these things
you
better need from here I'll never be from
here because I come from a completely
different background but nobody held a
gun to my head and said you have to go
to Germany it's something I did by
myself and I built a life for myself
here that I'm totally happy with we
thought I'd blue clip in German in
practice I can't make a living from
sewing so I work in a cafe people here
have their stereotypes like they would
anywhere they expect somebody with
darker skin at first just as a joke I'd
say what did you expect that I have
bananas on my head you guys could
Thailand with when the days get to be so
grey you can look out over the harbor
and I think to yourself how much you'd
rather be somewhere else
when I fly to Argentina there's so much
excitement
everyone's hugging and kissing you and
all talking at once it's all of it much
when you first get there at long last
Victoria Bergen is back in her hometown
in her old home country even if it's
just for a visit but this time instead
of wiling away the days in Buenos Aires
she'll be setting out from here on a
journey through Argentina a personal
journey to see friends and relatives she
hasn't seen in years
first she heads to the or Kisa district
of the Big Apple to see her family
my mother died 12 years ago I have two
younger sisters one is studying
Landscape Architecture and the other
international commerce and she's working
with my dad
my papa my dad owns a workshop for car
air conditioners you know I think I
learned quite a lot of things from
watching my dad and his attitude to life
he's a very calm person and he just
tries to enjoy his life one day at a
time then live in Sudanese and didn't
talk ah my bottom part of the cabinet
you have an advancement my family's
always worried when I come to visit
because I always find really interesting
things I can take back with me to use
for brooches and bags and all kinds of
stuff it's just a part of being home to
rummage through these things
les McKeown monocyte is what fascinates
me about when it's Aries are these huge
buildings and all the different people
it's a city always on the move
you got there people here have a
completely different lifestyle they want
to set themselves apart brand names
mobile phones and cars are important to
them
just north of the megalopolis Buenos
Aires where the Rio paraná empties into
the Rio de la Plata is a wetland area
made up of countless tributaries canals
and small islands
it's where the porteño says the city's
inhabitants are known go to commune with
nature
I'm Papa Hoth I'm Steve my dad has a
house on an island out Antigua and he
spends his weekends there that's where
he goes to relax and I grew up with it
this is these are all my girlfriends and
my whole family come along on outings
there and I'm especially glad to have my
grandma along unfallen freud me does my
neuroma occupies my no Maya Smith my
grandmother emigrated to Argentina from
Austria when she was five years old
she studied arts and became an architect
I'd like to be as fit as she is when I'm
86 BC Sousa miss them do you ever miss
Argentina yes yes I do a lot I miss my
family and friends and the weather yes
sometimes I just miss a few hugs nice oh
well maybe not quite that bad but it's
different it's another culture that you
have to deal with in another way you're
in a foreign country and you tend to
idealize your own country yeah so it can
do so well for one thing I can tell you
quite a lot has changed here with the
politics the government wants everybody
to think just like they do and that's
just not possible as everyone should
find acceptance in the country everyone
read I lay a leg woodchuck I'll continue
in Spanish Joe Carioca
I think another of the problems here is
that for one thing there are more poor
people all the time and at the same time
the quality of education has gotten a
lot worse
pero también let ocasion that hits the
poor even harder ESO provoke devil edad
el pobre no I never get an opportunity
to make something of themselves and find
a dignified job hey blondie hey bro
Rosario encontrar un trabajo de no well
yeah it's easier to govern stupid people
isn't it Boris abouthe exactly you can
promise a stupid person anything and
even if you don't keep your word he'll
still believe you and vote for you if
they won't then
Victoria's journey takes her on a
thousand kilometres north across the
Parana River to Chaco Province
some people call this region the
poorhouse of Argentina it's a hot dry
region especially in the summer heat
Victoria is here to see a relative of
hers Martine she hasn't seen him in
seven years
yeah yeah yeah linear Oh God
is that even a lot again yeah
Martinez Martine is a brother of my aunt
he's originally from Buenos Aires but
he's been living in the Chaco for a few
years now he fell in love with gobby
here
now she's his wife they're working
together on a social project in the
Chuckle where they help young people in
their development I wrote the name of
myself in a playable doesn't get the
children to come here at all and except
this house has the place where they live
that casa en Vanessa you are born with
passion
you notice that we have company
this is Victoria she comes from Buenos
Aires but she's been living in Germany
for many years now a country that's far
far away somebody's he get a sandal
equals flowered martini machine has
always liked to help others and this is
the perfect place for it they really
need help and with as little money as
they have here what they're doing is a
real challenge
if Donna had all faux pas SI dem are
your qualities no listen Anna many of
the parents tell us they don't know how
to teach their children the material
from school but often it's not a matter
of solving maths problems or explaining
the rules of grammar it's mostly a
matter of just being present that's what
makes a child want to learn and best of
all it helps to bring parents and
children closer more toward our life
you're nearly there
I think my team
what's this land used for Oh deke
nominated originally it wasn't used for
anything and then people started tossing
away all kinds of things here most of
what you see lying around here is
plastic trash and bottles
this has e como la casa Dominica and
since the houses stand very close there
are lots of problems with infections
even with dengue fever
ding when the first deaths occurred it
triggered a nationwide campaign but
nothing ever came of it I said that I
mean I'll go feed and then he said when
I see children playing in trash like
this it really hurts me Argentina could
have so much wealth there's so much that
could be done here
really
from near Victoria travels in other 600
kilometers west to see Carlos nazar an
archaeologist
carlos teaches at a small provincial
university in an old colonial town this
is the Cathedral of the Our Lady of the
valley the patron saint of Catamarca the
architecture has a touch of classical
and a touch of Romanesque the madonna
was discovered in a grotto seven
kilometres north of here by an India
horn Indiana
Carlos may well be dreaming of making a
discovery like that himself he suggests
a little outing to an ancient inca
fortress outside town we got a marker a
very big province with many different
picturesque landscapes and Argentina's
most important archaeological heritage
as well
a timer kappa
participator marker was part of the
Andean world what is there nothing good
that's why the Incas had such great
regard for this place even before the
eyes
they were very developed cultures here
sights on this scale are of great
interest colleges the best escolarium
ozone attract Evo's para para cualquier
archeo lo
like one key here is the fortunes of a
con [ __ ] was the principal base on the
eastern frontier the southern Inca
Empire and it's the most important
archaeological site in northwestern
Argentina simply one winter my simple
temple neurosurgeon T Lincoln L Aquila
Larissa the Incas sought out strategic
locations that were easy to defend akan
[ __ ] is very high up and it's virtually
impregnable landings EEMA
he will always think of Peru when they
think of the Incas I think it's very
interesting to see how these buildings
were constructed the techniques used on
these stones and the way they're joined
it's hard to believe that such an old
civilization was able to do this I guess
he really had to that's Matthew cuando
los incas he did I only say more the
Incas built this rampart and then filled
it in with rubble to level the area
inside that's how they were able to join
these two Hills together it's a
monumental feat
phone Columba I'd already heard a lot
about Helen passion national park
friends and family have been there and
told me I absolutely had to go and I'm
completely fascinated by it sign of need
to fund of this [ __ ] visa had never
been in the desert before and it's just
incredible these shapes and stone
formations have you never seen a
landscape like this in my life
Mendoza capital of the province of that
name is known for its many parks and
mild climate at the foot of the Andes
it's also known as the city of wine
Victoria is here to meet Jose a family
friend he's studying enology
the science of wine while having a look
around town they run into a
demonstration these people are
demonstrating about healthcare the
hospitals don't have enough resources or
staff to care for all the patients they
have the work is hard enough already so
we've been having these strikes and
protests marches for a week now
synthesized ether dusty maybe I actually
think it's great that health care
workers are fighting for the rights and
fair pay but left wingers and poor women
showed up and confuse the whole issue of
it and Here I am watching a
demonstration and I don't know exactly
what it's about because I'm a stranger
here ready can [ __ ] strengthen Jose
invites Victoria to visit a vineyard
outside Mendoza the bodega run Isaiah
where he works off and on
enesta fauna El Castillo it's mainly the
Malbec variety of grape that thrives in
this region
but I sorrows are say tenemos la ventaja
the advantage of this climate is that
the days are very warm and there's very
little precipitation young from
sanitarium and the vineyards are very
healthy and hardly need any care or
treatment with pesticides come from PC
and how are the vines irrigated in rio
de la planta the water comes from
melting snow up in the Andes Gabriel we
innately like what is it but climate
change is causing a huge problem for us
now a precipitation during winter is
getting very sparse and cano longer meet
the demand for water in the region it's
actually becoming a lot harder to get
good harvests difficile lol I do not
know when Abruzzo
later that evening after the first glass
of wine Jose has a few questions of his
own so what's the difference between
Argentinian and German men were more
warm-hearted admit that at least well
here it's easier to get to know people
but I'd never understood exactly why we
act like beginners when chatting up
women don't we know but I've never
understood how people get together there
I think it's hard so ABC why are you
women hard to find no I don't know the
German men just don't come up and hit on
me oh so you go on the offensive
no I don't but in Germany nobody looks
at me it's hard yeah well then here's a
message to the German men go for it you
know it yes I said again yeah exactly
every type test
Felisha Dharma Mandy
a photo fo kalapa concerto Calma salata
depend Oh
arrows capicola Rita Marlowe and Oh
stolen a coy
okay okay
[ __ ]
1300 kilometers due south Victoria
arrives in Elba song destination of
social dropouts many of them refugees
from Buenos Aires Victoria is here to
see your friend Marianna
who's lived here for several years now
my dear nakanishi on side I've known
Marianna since childhood we grew up
together you feel very differently about
someone you've known for such a long
time the last time I saw her was I think
four or five years ago in Germany I'm
very excited to see her family and how
she's living now yeah Mariana and her
husband Marcello run a little mountain
lodge together and they want Victoria to
see it they found some horses and a
guide to take them up to it
My dear neva show me tani-san I wouldn't
say Mariana has ever really been a city
person we lived in the country I see her
as being much closer to nature and as
far as our friendship goes friendships
like ours never change no matter how
long you haven't seen each other with a
real friendship you can see the other
person and it's if no time pass it all
and that's the way it is with her
Oh oh yeah yeah you are
hey Viji mah boring we're here at last
it's a long way but it's beautiful
see when a deputy go just look in
addition to this lodge there's a
circular track up on lago de anotación
with more cabins it don't feel quick
today do you stay up here the whole
summer hey Martha November same is
Marcelo comes up in November and stays
six months I don't stay as long because
go to school but from December on I'm up
here most of the time
Marcelo from November onwards then in
February and March we go back down can
you make a living from the lodge or for
here oh no no no no more cars arms I
look after children we try to survive we
don't have any steady jobs down below
don't book like it then with almost Elon
some trauma do you miss blender series
oh not at all I'm so glad I can raise my
children out in nature I'm happy that
they know how to gather wood and they
know what a fire is without all the
clutter of civilization even without
electricity they spend all their time
playing in mother nature yes otra vez on
tempo wanna put in a two Danny's
Victoria's journey takes her yet another
thousand kilometres south to where the
world-famous glacier perito morino rises
not far from the town of el calafate a
this an alternation amazeen
this is a place I've always wanted to
see yeah you arrive here and it's really
impressive these colors these are fallen
is this texture Oh lovely it's
incredible that nature can build such a
nice block
Filipa don't deserve me this journey
meant a whole lot of impressions I can
take back with me Argentina is a country
where people are very warm and easy to
get acquainted with but it's also like a
roller coaster ride what's true today
can be totally different tomorrow unites
the AMA the people alert work work six
or seven days a week many of them have
two or three jobs it makes you realize
how good we've still got it in Germany
at the moment I couldn't even begin to
imagine living here at the end of her
journey Victoria calls on her uncle
Thomas he's a professor of philosophy a
thinker Thomas Abram was born in Romania
to Hungarian and German parents and he
studied in France the concept of home is
understandably one close to his heart I
needed a place for me I'd lived in
France and Japan and various countries
but I didn't find what I needed my place
was here from here I observed the world
not thing I don't identify with a
national culture I don't feel I owe any
loyalty to anything or anyone unless I
wish to so you could say I'm integrated
here but retain the freedom to back out
at any time
I don't like patriotism no me gusta
patio tea a less harsh leftist
everything's got its good and bad sides
and what I've realized for myself and my
life on this journey is that I need to
try to lay the bad part aside and just
take the best parts of both cultures my
home country is Argentina but I come
from Hamburg almost humble